le 15 février 2021 patrick poivre
d'arvor est accusé de viol par florence
porcel patrick poivre d'arvor est accusé
par une écrivaine florence porcel qui
accuse l'ancien présentateur du 20
heures de tf1 de viol depuis les langues
se délier au total onze femmes ont porté
plainte contre l'ex présentateur du 20h
pour viol agressions ou harcèlement sur
une longue période allant de 1985 à 2015
certaines restent anonymes huit femmes
ont pourtant décidé récemment de faire
la couverture de libération au delà de
révéler les actes dont elles ont été
victimes elle dénonce le non lieu qui
avait été prononcée en faveur de ppda en
juin dernier patrick poivre d'arvor
vient de se voir innocenté en cas de
classer sans suite pour prescription
mais parmi ses victimes une explique
soutenir et défendre patrick poivre
d'arvor elle s'appelle alessandra fera
et elle a pourtant été la cible
d'agressions sexuelles à trois reprises
par le journaliste elle est avec nous ce
soir pour nous expliquer pourquoi elle
le défend
merci alessandra fera d'être avec vous
êtes romancière vous êtes auteur et
fondatrice de l'association le paris
littéraire vous avez j'allais raconter
xi a été victime du comportement de
patrick poivre d'arvor et pourtant vous
le soutenez la première fois que vous
rencontrez ppda on est en 2005 vous avez
22 ans aucune expérience avec les
garçons et vous allez tomber amoureuse
de lui c'est ça oui c'est ça j'ai lu un
de ses livres je n'étais pas ici et j'ai
écrit un petit mot j'ai été très marqué
par ce livre écrit quoi que voilà je
trouvais son témoignage bouleversant et
que je m'identifiais bien voilà danger
vous étiez fan en fait de deux doigts de
fait jouer au jeu l'auteur j'avais
beaucoup vécu à l'étranger donc c'était
pas forcément un personnage pour moi
très familier c'est le livre voilà c'est
le livre qui m'a vraiment beaucoup sais
pas quoi le présentateur d'une enseigne
c'est l'auteur exact témoignages qu'il a
livré dans son livre donc voulu créer un
petit bout et là ils vous répondent ces
sahraouis il m'envoie une petite carte
avec le logo tf1 d'accord disait venez
veut voir un soir pour le jt nous
parlerons d'accord donc la dudh pas
c'est sympa ah oui bah oui j'aime
beaucoup parler moins sûr voilà
l'échangé est sympa d'aller voir comment
se passent eux aussi comptabilité de 20
heures c'est vrai que voilà donc vous
dites vous chez j vais vous allez à tf1
oui je suis allé à tf1 quand j'y suis
allé une première fois dans l'après-midi
d'accord parce que j'avais pas forcément
envie le soir moi ça m'attirait pas
forcément d'aller au jt oui mais la
deuxième fois j'ai accepté encore à ça
demain lors la première fois qu'on vous
y allez vous y allez en après midi vous
le rencontrez dans son bureau oui dans
son bureau en ce moment je ne sens pas
plus d'une heure et demie d'entretien
aux travaux le fait que vous parlez
l'espace hurlait que parler ou lui dit
votre amour pour le livre voilà vers la
fin bon il me pose pas mal de questions
indiscrètes toujours comment si j'avais
un fiancé voilà si j'avais des relations
avec des garçons mais assez gentil enfin
d'accord voilà et là il s'aventure sur
des moteurs les banques oui j'étais
célibataire je rentrais d'angleterre de
cambridge d'accord voilà vous lui disent
que vous êtes célibataire je lui dis ça
et là il s'avance vers moi d'accord il
vous fait qu'est ce qui fait que
voilages
me pose un peu des questions je me
demande ce qu'il va faire je suis un peu
tétanisé dessus effectivement mais je
pense qu'il s'en rend compte et qui
s'adapte et donc ils m'embrassent sur le
front d'accord voilà bien donc là vous
vous dites vous repartez chez vous vous
dites franchement je vous êtes un petit
peu amoureuse voilà je me dis vraiment
c'est un gentleman du marbre a fait sur
le front il est
même un petit coup de c'ur oui j'ai un
petit coup de coeur effectivement je me
dis voilà il s'est bien comporté bon
même vous l'aimez bien vous les aimiez
bien il est énorme c'est vrai donc voilà
vous avez un petit coup dur donc la peau
vous vous rentrez chez vous vous voyez
comment ils nous envoient c'est lui qui
vous dit pas c'est un soir oui il
entretient des liens avec des petits
mots d'epicor toujours avec souvent le
logo tf1 d'accord je pense que c'est un
système un peu rodé ces cartes voilà et
donc quelques mois quand je reconnais
qu'avec le c8 et
j'en passe je leur mets de l'argent vous
serez et donc oui mais voilà et donc au
bout d'un moment oui j'accepte en
septembre d'aller le voir
l'assister au gîte d'accord donc la
ville et pour la deuxième fois que
j'assiste au jt oui tout à la fin du jt
vous allez le voir alors j'assiste au jt
après effectivement tout le monde part
oui me retrouve seule à élever dans sa
loge mais c'est juste à côté une loge
ouverte mais y'a plus personne les
locaux sont vides donc je m'avance vers
lui je discute un peu en disant que
voilà moi je cherche une relation
romantique a déjà vous êtes en train de
vous vous avez envie d'avoir une
relation romantique de denfert votre
compagnon voilà un petit peu mais c'est
ça vous dit oui à la pour vous êtes vous
avez quand même un petit croche oui j'ai
un petit croche et je lui ai dit voilà
vous parlez de ça tous les deux vous lui
direz vous lui dites voilà vous plaisez
mémoire je veux une relation romantique
celle là pour ça pas là pour être un une
relation d'un soir c'est exactement ce
que je suis d'accord très bien mais
j'étais pas là en plus on
vient très bien et donc ils m'écoutent
et on vous il m'écoute en regardant bien
droit dans les yeux et il me dit oui
c'est compliqué la tâche man etc
d'accord il vous fait comprendre que il
vous aime bien mais que ce serait pas
pour faire voilà une histoire aux yeux
et au su de tout le monde voilà tout à
fait ça vous vous c'est ça vous cherchez
un amoureux oui exact pas nous oui voilà
j'avais un idéal et c'est ça le plus
correspondait mais lui il n'était pas
dans ce délire parce qu'il voulait juste
voilà il vous a expliqué qu à vous ai
dit quoi et il m'a pas dit qu'ils
cherchaient juste une nuit mais il m'a
dit moi l'attachement on va ne
m'intéresse pas vraiment sûr très
compliqué j'ai pas le temps pour ça ma
vie est compliquée il répétait souvent
ma vie est compliquée voilà donc là ils
sont vingt vous vous dites bon se sert à
rien donc oui je me dis bon enfin
j'insiste pas trop long mais voilà je
lui dis est ce que tu es vous êtes bien
sûr voilà alors dévoilé là il me dit
tout d'un coup suivez-moi d'accord donc
je suis et je lui demande mais on va où
et il dit on pourrait nous entendre donc
je le suis moi je pense qu'on va en fait
je pense qu'on va vers sa voiture et que
voilà il m'emmène quelque part d'inné
enfin
imagination et en fait non pas du tout
il m'emmène dans l'escalier de secours
mais moi toujours
pas rigoler ça
mais je vous dis alors alexandra rigole
mais c'est vrai absolument voilà oui
avec le recul c'est parce que danser
comme nous le raconter c'est vrai qu'on
peut comprendre le public parce que vous
nous dites voilà vous vous étiez dans
une relation romantique vous dites voilà
je vais pas un vaudeville qualcomm de
l'innocence qui ne fait soit là mais
bientôt on est comme aller son mario je
peux comprendre là que le public ait un
vrai mais c'est vrai que si c'est grave
donc là là vous allez dans les skateurs
louis et là moi je pense toujours qu'on
va à la voiture d'encore turbo est ce
que vous dites voilà exactement donc je
le suis et tout d'un coup ils s'arrêtent
ici mobilisent sur le palier et là il
commence à me entreprendre voilà donc
vous faites quoi page le repousse
d'accros je pousse tout de suite tu me
dis mais qu'est ce que tu qu'est ce que
vous faites ça va pas non je le pousse
d'accord et là tout de suite il me dit
ah ça vous fait pas plaisir que je vous
touche
et s'arrêtent d'accord voilà c'est
immédiat comme n'insiste pas et voilà
donc là vous faites quoi vous rentrez
chez vous oui je rentre chez moi aux
failles il s'en va en courant adacore il
part en courant dans les escaliers
d'accord après avoir dit ça semble dire
au revoir il s'en va en courant il dit
on se reverra quand ma vie sera moins
compliqué il me dit avant de partir en
courant ok donc là c'est là la deuxième
rencontre
oui qu'est ce qui se passe après six
bouts qui le relance et où c'est lui oui
je le relance parce que je veux avoir
une explication et quand vous êtes dans
l'eau dans le dans le
vous dites dans l'escalier de service
juste il fait quoi au juste il essaie de
vous embrasser oui m'embrasse et il m'en
lasse il met sa main dans mon pantalon
quand même d'accord mais ça n'a pas
vraiment beaucoup plus loin d'accord un
plat leurs pouces assez rapidement et
qu'il n'est pas violent corps et tri vie
qui part voilà il dit on se reverra
voilà ma vie sera moins compliqué malle
arrière d'affaires
derrière donc aller ça c'est vous qui le
relancer oui c'est moi parce que je
voulais avoir une explication et je suis
une personne qui aime aller au bout des
choses la comprendre au début vous
vouliez pas une relation d'un soir mais
vous aviez eu un vrai crush pour elle a
fait des examens ou servier si vous avez
dit on fait une histoire ensemble et on
se met ensemble vous auriez dit oui oui
voilà oui éventuellement oui c'est super
petit à petit voilà exactement où il
n'était pas très pressé mais voilà avec
le temps où il donc là vous le lancez
vous lui dites quoi je lui dis pas
j'aimerais bien qu'on discute de tout ce
qui s'est passé cette soir ce soir là
donc on a dansé ce mercredi là dans
l'escalier justement pourquoi pourquoi
que vous vous comportez ainsi en vous
voyez à l'époque et puis voilà
finalement il m'a vite de nouveaux gîtes
et d'annoncer sa pratique habituelle unc
la bourre sur une carte de terrain ouais
non non il me téléphone ou la corée là
il fixe à une date et j'y vais en
décembre donc vous y allez là vous
agissez au gîte et encore oui j'insiste
de nouveau gta vous allez dans l'art
lanthier mais ça fait partie du procès
voilà vous allez dans la loge donc fait
un prénom là on me mène à son bureau ça
se son assistante m'emmène dans son
bureau qui était plongée dans le noir
elle est juste à côté et j'attends
j'attends un certain temps avant qu'il
arrive ou alors je me dis bon on va bien
pouvoir discuter et
donc la troisième rencontre oui est ce
que vous êtes stressé quand il arrivait
que vous retrouvez seul média toujours
son assistante annonce en assistante et
à côté et je trouverais stressé oui
d'accord oui elle est allée y est
vraiment à la fin à craon d'accord qui
lui ou son assistant lui et son
assistante elle me jette des regards un
peu bizarre oui d'accord donc ils sont
strictes donc là il arrive et qu'est ce
qui se passe tout de suite je lui je lui
dis voilà j'aimerais qu'on coach que
vous vous expliquer sur votre
comportement
dans l'escalier je voudrais comprendre
pourquoi vous agissez ainsi
quel est votre psychologie enfin moi je
m'intéresse beaucoup à la psychologie
donc je suis posé des questions pour
essayer de comprendre pourquoi et
pourquoi il veut pas d'attachement
pourquoi il entreprend si vite une femme
éprouvée question mais pourquoi il est
parti dans l'escalier qu'est ce qu'ils
cherchent f pourquoi il se comporte
comme ça alors qu'est ce que c'est pas
bien tu sois là lui répond déjà sur le
l'attachement déjà en premier oui il
vous dit quoi et il commence à s'agiter
il nie tout en bloc qui dit qui a rien
eu dans l'escalier de secours il fait
comme si rien n'avait eu que j'avais
tout imaginé que c'était un fantasme de
ma part et que rien ne s'était passé
dans cet escalier voilà il n'y a pas de
discussion à voir j'ai été clair dès le
début je ne veux pas la tâche et j'ai
été très gentils en vous recevant
plusieurs fois en écoutant voilà et je
vois pas pourquoi maintenant vous me
posez ces questions et j'ai pas vous
répondre on se connaît pas on se connaît
pas il répète plusieurs fois on se
connait pas ton qui a pas d'explication
à voir et l'ail congédie son assistante
il lui dit dès que ça monte un peu que
le ton monte un peu il lui dit il faut
il va t'en d'accord puisqu'ils et or
n'ont plus soyez d'état il ya plus
personne 12 heures bah oui et puis
finale j'étais aventure qu on me dit ça
elle a attendu longtemps il est 21h30 à
la haye ce qui est assez frappant c'est
que les couloirs de tf1 sont déserts le
soir y'a plus personne
n'y a pas de caméra j'imagine à l'époque
je sais pas mais en tout cas cessé
désert alors là vous retrouvez donc seul
avec lui son assistante est parti il
vous dit que tout ça est le fruit de
votre imagination exact de deuxième
ronde ça et là qu'est ce qui se passe
j'insiste je veux savoir je veux
comprendre je lui dis mais il faut que
tu trouves que vous vous expliquez moi
je suis en fait dû faire une thérapie
bout et c'est ça que je veux le lui
faire prendre conscience voilà que ça va
pas du tout ce comportement qu'il faut
qu'ils changent et puis moi comme
j'avais des quelque part des sentiments
bien sûr je veux le bolide est faite aux
autres c'est un peu ou d'essayer de
l'aider oui j'essaie de l'aider j'essaye
de comprendre ce qui va pas dans son
esprit et je me dis que voilà ça m'a pas
fait plaisir cette intervention dans
l'escalier voilà et que et que j'aimerai
que comprendre pourquoi il m'a envoyé
des petits mots et pourquoi il a il a
joué ce jeu là et que je trouve pas ça
bien voilà je me dit plusieurs fois que
je trouve pas ça bien ce type de
comportement ça c'est en décembre 2005
oui
hélas
il dit en plus menaçants wedin s'énerve
énormément mais pas parce qu'il a envie
d'une relation sexuelle avec moi mais
pas du tout le corps et parce que je le
racisme lui pose des questions je le
soumets un peu un interrogatoire comme à
apple police enfin je lui ai dit voilà
il faut il faut s'expliquer maintenant
et lui devient très très agressif itable
du point il me menacer dit qu'il faut
que je sorte je lui dis bah appelé la
sécurité alors là il s'écrit à vous
cherchez le scandale maintenant j'ai
compris pourquoi vous êtes là c'est pour
le scandale donc sa part dans dans une
dispute de plus en plus forte en fait
voilà qu'en mais là
c'est quoi au plus fort de disputes il
fait quoi il menace du point voilà enfin
il fait comme ça devant mon visage voilà
sans s'en aller je dois pas touché non
il me touche pas non sauf à la fin oui
mais ses mains sur ma gorge oui ça c'est
vrai mais bon je pense pas qu'il voulait
mettre en rire il voulait que je sorte
il voulait que je pars il voulait que ça
cesse c'est que vous vouliez vous
vouliez pas partir ensuite vous lire le
vois pas partir parce que je suis c'est
ma nature j'aime bien aller au bout des
choses j'aime la vérité c'est pour ça
que je suis là aussi ce soir j'aime bien
des explications j'aime comprendre
j'aime la psychologie j'aime aller au
bout des choses ou alors donc là c'est
donc là de troisième rencontre
avec ppda vous partez final oui je pars
finalement c'est ce que vous vous dites
je pense a dit je répète plusieurs fois
vous êtes vous avez peur ou pas du tout
vous dit jamais vraiment qu est-ce qu
enfin je sais pas je suis pas d'une
nature à avoir peur et puis c'est pas
qu'ils voulaient avoir des rapports
sexuels avec moi alors donc supporter
pas mon insistance à connacht supportait
pas que lui dit vous êtes fou à cinq
reprises et puis il me dit vous
comprenez pas toute cette douleur et
voilà ça se termine comme ça et je m'en
vais donc là vous portez je pars ouais
vous êtes lui vous laisser dans son
bureau au sol vous parti seul dans son
bureau il ya plus personne je pars tout
seul d'ailleurs il ya des sur vos
réponses vous portez sans mes réponses
et puis je peins et puis à personne
pourra compte pour m'accompagner pour ya
plus personne à part en bas dans le hall
ya peut-être une personne tous ces
locaux sont déserts évident voilà fait
alors
5 ou plus tard
je n'ai plus de nouvelles pendant cinq
ans non je le croise à des événements
littéraires comporte avec vous il est
sympa oui il est plutôt sympa au malin
mais comme tu fais comme si de rien
n'était il m'appelle alessandra voilà
donc tout se passe bien tout se passe
bien et enfin voila vous l'avez jamais
rôle afin non tout de suite après j'ai
écrit quand même mon livre tout de suite
dans la foulée en 2006 un suicide - un
roman qui raconte vraiment l'histoire de
ces rencontres
ça ça me sont des boucs sur le sens cité
mais avec quand même son illustration en
couverture on peut le reconnaître et je
fais comprendre à certains journalistes
que c'est lui wells a réagi patron nonce
a réagit pas trop je pense que sortait
chst était différent et la parole
pouvait pas être entendus en face ce
type de témoignage en tout cas et puis
encore une fois il n'y avait pas eu viol
j'ai corrigé c'est ce que vous dites
depuis le début
cinq ans plus tard
vous allez vous retrouver chez lui
vous allez nous raconter cette quatrième
rencontre comment ça se fait qu'on
retrouve vous retrouviez chez ppda cinq
ans plus tard c'est par rapport à la
parution d'un livre que voilà j'avais
j'avais des questions à lui posées par
rapport à ça par rapport à une recherche
d'éditeur d'ailleurs je tiens à dire
qu'il faut savoir que beaucoup de
personnes qui le fréquentaient étaient
en attente de quelque chose de conseil
ou ou deux voies la dette dans le monde
littéraire ouais moi c'était mon cas
aussi je voulais voilà qui me concerne
éditeurs ou qui me conseille dans mon
écriture quand on vous dit des conseils
mais a fait aller sans toutes les
personnes qui nous regardent ce soir on
se dira s'est mal passé deux fois elles
sont à cinq ans après elle va demander
des conseils ppd alors est ce qu'elle
n'a pas pu demander des conseils
quelqu'un dont tu joues jour je me fais
l'avocat du diable je vous pose des
questions qui doivent se poser
actuellement chez noter un spectateur ça
s'est mal passé avec lui mais j'ai dit
non je pensais je pense toujours jeu que
une femme peut dire non elle peut dire
non même plusieurs fois si elles le
souhaitent j'avais pas envie de
forcément de couper les ponts avec lui
j'estimais aussi qu'on avait eu une
sorte de vote des changes en fin de
deuxième ici ce sont nos téléspectateurs
qui nous rejoindre vous vous avez
vraiment un break roche pour lui un
voile a tellement j'avais bien oui il a
des côtés quand même énormément voilà
vous êtes bien et j'avais envie de vous
êtes attiré par lui crû plus plus au
genre dit non avant à l'époque on parle
n'est pas la même histoire que lui en
tout cas exane voulait une histoire
d'amour elle aurait pu faire une
histoire avec patrick poivre d'arvor est
une amie lui voulait une aventure voilà
d'un soir après j'ai voulu garder une
amitié je l'aimé bien et puis j'avais vu
ses côtés sombres mais ça veut pas dire
c'est pas parce qu'une personne a des
côtés sombres qu'on coupe les ponts avec
lui et j'avais dit non ils avaient
respecté mon nom après tout voilà ça
s'était très mal passé la dernière fois
mais j'avais beaucoup insisté pour avoir
des explications
donc voilà je n'étais pas non plus dans
le calme moi non plus j'ai insisté
normes et ment et il était un peu voilà
dans une position difficile où ils
étaient sommés de répondre d'accord
alors maintenant on va parler de cette
affaire que vous êtes chez lui cinq ans
plus tard et de ce qui se passe ce que
vous pensez que vous étiez sous forme
d'un prix c'est-à-dire de fascination
pour lui a certes il avait une position
à l'époque afin après plus mais disons
qu'il y avait un lien qui s'était créé
du fait des événements précédents caisse
en 2005 qu'est ce qui se passe chez lui
vous allez chez lui à son domicile avait
chez lui et d'ailleurs je me suis
retrouvé plusieurs fois chez lui c'est à
la salle d'accord voilà hélas une fois
de plus j'étais obligé de dire non
qu'est ce qui s'est passé vous êtes tous
les autres choses chez lui voilà seul
chez lui il a de nouveau insisté c'est
mon tort il est ce qui se passe vous
êtes au départ vous prenez un verre
enfin même pas c'est pas trop son genre
d'offre inverse
il voit là ils posent des questions
qu'est ce que tu fais quels sont tes
projets et puis après des questions un
peu plus intime un peu plus des
comportements déplacés enfin elle
choléra est ce que tu as fait ans et
vient chercher dans l'époque non à
l'époque n'ont toujours quoi voilà mais
voilà ils posent des questions
insistantes sur ma vie personnelle et je
réponds plus ou moins parfois j'ai ça
vous gêne à bezannes un peu je trouve
que c'est déplacé d'accord donc là vous
étiez lui qu'est ce qu'il fait bah il
insiste il a su hisser son bras si non
ils voudraient des rapports dont qui
vous le dit oui me le dit ouais vous dit
quoi que il faudrait des rapports
sexuels et je dis non à chaque fois
c'est la même histoire avec vous dis oui
j'aimerais avoir les soins des rapports
sexuels avec vous qui est ce qu'est ce
que kate tu vas pas envie tu vas pas
envie d'un rapport avec moi
voilà qu'est ce qui te ferait plaisir
est ce qu'on peut avoir des rapports
enfin il est direct ici ils essayent il
tente sa chance il a fait quelque chose
pour vous montrer qu'ils voulaient faire
quelque chose il a eu un oui
il abaisse un peu son pantalon et voilà
c'est mais c'est bref je dis non et il
écoute mon nom et ils arrêtent ils
arrêtent et il est pas il a jamais à
aucun moment était violent brutal sauf
en décembre mais ça c'est celle un
contexte juriste vous avez raconté donc
oui je dis non mais moi ça me dérange
pas de dire non je pense que ça fait
partie de la vie d'une femme de dire non
de savoir dire non fermement aux
gentiment selon les cas mais je pense je
suis habitué à dire non je fais
constamment et pas qu'avec patrick
poivre d'arvor je les fais dans d'autres
contextes voilà donc d'accord alors un
problème pour moi
aujourd'hui vous vous soutenir oui
pourquoi
justement parce que mon expérience à
prouver que quand j'ai refusé on s'est
arrêté hélas il n'a pas fait preuve de
violence s'est pas montrée brutale et
vous vous dites quoi tous les
témoignages de jeunes femmes qu'on a
eues la semaine dernière dans libération
qu'on a pu dire voilà je pense qu'il y
avait un certain conteste à l'époque
aussi voilà certaines autres choquer
pour ces témoignages ce qu'ils sont sont
très forts oblige les élus après
certains évoquent plutôt des
comportements inappropriés c'est le cas
de muriel reus elle a parlé de
comportement inapproprié
vous comprenez que quelques il est peu
de choquer ou non oui je comprends qu'on
puisse être choqué je sais plus trop aux
tisanes parole j'ai pour ces témoignages
d'ailleurs j'ai été là bas dès le mois
de février j'ai été prête à témoigner à
visage découvert j'ai contacté le figaro
j'ai contacté le parisien pour livrer
mon témoignage quand je me suis rendu au
siège du parisien à leur demande reçue
par benoît daragon et mon témoignage
n'est jamais paru voilà peu parce qu'il
gênait parce que j'avais une parole plus
nuancée plus modéré plus médiane en
disant oui ces comportements sont
déplacés mais mais il n'est pas coupable
de viol et voilà il faut pas mettre sur
un même plan des gestes déplacés
inappropriés qui doivent être dénoncés
ça c'est certain et un violent parce que
si on commence à amalgamer les deux on
va pas sir john b vous êtes toujours à
mener avec les jaunes d'oeufs je suis
toujours en contact avec lui d'ailleurs
il m'a dit qu'il était triste que que
j'ai hurler avec la meute
d'accord mais après je expliqué que
voilà oui pour moi c'était très
important de livrer ces témoignages je
suis toujours pour la sincérité la
vérité je veux livrer un témoignage je
pense que ça fait avancer les choses et
ces comportements déplacés doivent
cesser mais voilà
il ne s'est pas caché là ce soir mais il
a compris mon témoignage en tout cas et
il ment n'a pas voulu aujourd'hui donc
vous le soutenez parce que pourquoi je
me suis je le soutiens parce que
justement je pense pas qu'on puisse
juger avec des critères présent les
affaires passées surtout après des
décennies surtout des affaires qui ont
eu lieu il ya 20 ans 30 ans et dans mon
cas en tout cas j'ai dit non et il a
écouté mon nom il a respecté mon nom